PROFESSOR PATRICK WINSTON: I was
in Washington for most of
the week prospecting for gold.
Another byproduct of that was
that I forgot to arrange a
substitute Bob Berwick for
the Thursday recitations.
I shall probably go
to hell for this.
In any event, we have
many explanations,
none of them good.
But today we'll try to get back
on track and you'll learn
something fun.
In particular you will learn how
a graduate student of mine
Mark [? Phillipson ?], together
with a summer UROP
student, Brett van Zuiden,
one of you--
managed to pull off a tour de
force and recognize in these
two descriptions the pattern
that we humans commonly call
"revenge." It was discovered.
The system didn't have a
name for it, of course.
It just knew that there was a
pattern there and sat waiting
for us to give a name to it.
That's where we're
going to end up.
But it'll be a bit of a journey
before we get there,
because we've got to
go through all that
stuff on the outline.
And in particular, we want
to start off by a
little tiny bit of review.
Because some of the stuff
we did last time
went by pretty fast.
In particular, you may remember
they had this
wonderful joint probability
table, which tells us all we
want to know, all
we want to know.
We can decide what the
probability of the police
being called is given the this
and the that, and all that
sort of stuff, by clicking
the appropriate boxes.
The trouble is, gee, there are
only three variables there.
And when there are lots of
variables it gets pretty hard
to make up those numbers or
to even collect them.
So we're driven to
an alternative.
And we got to that alternative
just at the end of
the show a week ago.
And we got to the point where
we were defining these
inference nets, sometimes called
"Bayes nets." And the
one we worked with
looked like this.
There's a burglar, a raccoon,
the possibility of a dog
barking, the police being
called, and a trash can being
overturned.
So more variables than that.
That only has three.
This has got five.
But we're able to do some magic
with this because we, as
humans, when we define--
when we draw this graph we're
making an assertion about how
things depend or don't depend
on one another.
In particular, there's something
to break down and
memorize to the point where
it rolls off your tongue.
And that is that any variable on
this graph is said by me to
be independent of any other
non-descendant given its parents.
Independent of any
So that means that the
probability of the dog
barking, given its parents,
doesn't depend on T, the trash
can being overturned.
Because the intuition is all
of the causality is flowing
through the parents and can't
get to this variable D without
going through the parents.
So that is [? inserted ?]
property of the nets
that we draw.
And we tend to draw them in a
way that reflects causality.
So it tends to make sense.
So somehow this thing
is going to be--
we're going to use this thing
instead of that thing.
But wait.
We may need that thing in
order to do all the
computations we want
to perform.
So we need to be able to show
that we can get to that thing
by doing calculations
on this thing.
So what to do?
Well, we're going to
use the chain rule.
And remember that the chain rule
came to us by way of the
basic Axioms of Probability
plus the definition plus a
little colored chalk.
So we got to the point
last time where we
sort of believed this.
It's a really magical thing.
It says that the probability
of all this stuff happening
together is given as the
product of a bunch of
conditional probabilities.
And the conditional
probabilities in this product
are arranged such that this
first guy depends
on everybody else.
The second guy doesn't depend
on the first guy but depends
on everything else.
So that list of dependencies
gets smaller and smaller as
you go down here until it
depends only one thing.
There's no conditional at all.
So that's going to come to our
rescue because it enables us
to go from calculations in
here to that whole table.
But first I have to show you a
little bit more slowly how
that comes to be.
One thing I'm going to do
before I think about
probability is I'm going to
make a linear list of all
these variables.
And the way I'm going to make
it is I'm going to chew away
at those variables
from the bottom.
I've taken advantage
of a very important
property of these nets.
And that is there no loops.
You can follow the arrows
in any way so as
you get back to yourself.
So there's always going
to be a bottom.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say, well, there are
two bottoms here, there's C
and T. So I have a choice.
I'm going to choose C. So I'm
going to take that off and
pretend it's not
there anymore.
Then I'm going to
take this guy.
That's now a bottom because
there's nothing below it.
I've already taken C out.
So we'll take that out next.
And now I've got this guy,
this guy, and this guy.
This guy no longer has
anything below it.
So I can list it next.
Now over here I've got
raccoon and trashcan.
But trashcan is at the bottom.
So I've got to take it next
because I'm working
from the bottom up.
I want to ensure that there are
no descendants before me
in this list.
So finally I get to raccoon.
So the way I constructed this
list like so ensures that this
list arranges the elements so
that for any particular
element, none of
its descendants
appear to its left.
And now that's the magical order
for which I want to use
the chain rule.
So now I can write--
I can pick C to be
my variable n.
And I can say that the chain
rule says that the joint
probability of all these
variables P of C,
D, B, T, and R--
the probability of any
particular combination of
those things is equal to the
probability of C given
everybody else.
Next in line is D given
Next in line is T--
next in line is B given
everybody else.
And next in line is T given
And finally, just R. So this
combination of things has a
probability that is given by
this chain rule expression.
Ah.
But first of all, none of those
expressions condition
any of the variables on
anything other than
non-descendants, all right?
That's just because of the way
I've arranged the variables.
And I can always do that
because are no loops.
I can always chew away
at the bottom.
That ensures that whenever I
write a variable, it's going
to be conditioned on stuff other
than its descendants.
So all of these variables in
any of these conditional
probabilities are
non-descendants.
Oh wait.
When I drew this diagram, I
asserted that no variable
depends on any non-descendant
given its parents.
So if I know the parents of
a variable I know that the
variable is independent of all
other non-descendants.
All right?
Now I can start scratching
stuff out.
Well, let's see.
I know that C, from my diagram,
has only one parent,
D. So given its parent, it's
independent of all other
non-descendants.
So I can scratch them out.
D he has two parents, B and R.
But given that, I can scratch
out any other non-descendant.
B is conditional on T and R.
Ah, but B has no parent.
So it actually is independent
of those two guys.
The trashcan, yeah, that's
dependent on R. And R over
here, the final thing in the
chain, that's just a
probability.
So now I have a way of
calculating any entry in that
table because any entry in that
table is going to be some
combination of values for
all those variables.
Voila.
So anything I can do with a
table, I can do in principle
with this little network.
OK?
But now the question is, I've
got some probabilities I'm
going to have to figure
out here.
So let me draw a slightly
different version of it.
So up here we've got the a
priori probability of B. Well,
that's just probability of B.
Down here with the dog, I've
got a bigger table because I've
got probabilities that
depend on the values
of its parents.
The probability of dog barking
depends on the condition of
the parents, nothing else.
So let's see.
I've got to have a column for
B. I've got to have a column
for the burglar and
the raccoon.
And there are a bunch of
possibilities for those guys.
But once I get those then I'll
be able to calculate the
probability of the
dog barking.
So there are two of
these variables.
So there are four
combinations.
There's T T. There's
T R, R T, and--
whoa, what am I doing?
Wake up!
T false.
False true.
And false false.
So what I really want to do is
I want to calculate all of
these probabilities that give
the probability of the dog
condition of the burglar
and the raccoon.
Similarly, I want to calculate
the probability of B happening
doesn't depend on
anything else.
So I don't know what to do.
Well, what I'm going to actually
do is I'm going to do
the same thing I had
to do up there.
I'm going to keep track of--
I'm going to try a bunch of--
I'm going to get myself together
a bunch of data.
Maybe I do a bunch
of experiments.
Maybe somebody hands it to me.
But I'm going to use that data
to construct a bunch of
tallies which are going to end
up giving me the probabilities
for all of those things.
So I don't know, let's see.
How should we start?
Step one, find colored chalk.
Step two, I'm going to extend
these tables a little bit so I
can keep track of the tallies.
So this is going to be all
the ones that end up in a
particular row.
And these are going to be the
ones for which dog is true.
Similarly, I'm going to extend
this guy up here in order to
keep track of some tallies.
This is going to be the ones
for which B is true.
And this one will be all.
So that's my set up.
And now suppose that my first
experiment comes roaring in.
And it's all T's.
So I have T T T. That's my first
experimental result, my
first data item.
So let's see.
The arrangement here is
burglar, raccoon, dog.
So burglar as a true.
And there's one tally
count in there.
Likewise, the T T, that's the
burglar and the raccoon, that
brings me down to
this first row.
So that gives me one tally in
there and dog is true so that
gives me a tick mark
in that one.
All right?
Are you with me so far?
And now let's suppose
that the next thing
happens be all false.
Well, burglar is false.
But there is one experiment.
Everybody's false.
So we come down here
to false false.
And that's the row we're
going to work on.
We get a tally in there.
Do we put one in here?
No, because that's false.
Dog is false.
That's what our data
element says.
So that's cool.
Maybe one more.
Let's suppose we have T T F.
Well in that case, we have a
tick mark here and a tick mark
here because the burglar
element is true.
Then we have T T. That brings
us to the first row again.
So we get a tick mark there.
But dog as false, so
no tick mark there.
That's how it works.
I suppose you'd like to see
a demonstration, right?
Always like to see
a demonstration.
So here's what it actually
looks like.
So on the left you see the
network as we've constructed
it, with a bunch probabilities
there.
And what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to start
simulating away so as to
accumulate tick marks, tally
marks, and see what kinds of
probabilities that they
indicate for the table.
I happen to be using a process
for which the model on the
left is a correct reflection.
So there's one simulation.
So the dog barking--
let's see, the burglar
is false.
The raccoon is true.
I get one tick mark.
So the probability
there is one.
Of course, I'm not going
to just go with one.
I want to put a whole bunch
of stuff in there.
So I'll just run a bunch
more simulations.
No [? dice. ?]
I don't even have an entry
at all yet for T F here.
That's because I haven't
run enough data.
So let me clear it instead of
doing it one at a time.
Let me run 100 simulations.
See, it's still not too good.
Because it says this T
T probability true.
This just because I'm feeding
it data, right?
And I'm keeping track of what
the data elements tell me
about how frequently a
particular combination appears.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: So when you're doing
one simulation, is that
[INAUDIBLE] variables?
PROFESSOR PATRICK WINSTON: When
I'm doing one simulation,
I'm just keeping track of
that combination in
each of these tables.
Because it's going to tell
me something about the
probabilities that I want
reflected in those tables.
So it's pretty easy to see when
I go up here to burglar.
If I have a lot of data
elements, they're all going to
tell me something about
the burglar as well
as the other variables.
So if I just look at that
burglar thing, the fraction of
time that it turns out true over
all the data elements is
going to be its probability.
So now when I go down to the
joint tables, I can still get
these probability numbers.
But now they're conditioned
on reticular
condition of its parents.
So that's how I get these
probabilities.
So I didn't do too well here
because that T T combination
gave me an excessively
high probability.
So maybe 100 simulations
isn't enough.
Let's run 10,000.
So with that much data running
through, the probabilities I
get-- let's see, I've got 893
here, instead of 0.9, 807
instead of 0.8, 607
instead of 0.6.
And that one's dead-on
at 0.01.
So if I run enough of these
simulations, I get a pretty
good idea what the probabilities
ought to be
given that I've got
a correct model.
OK, so that takes care
of that one.
And of course, I didn't draw
the other things in here.
But by extension, you can see
how those would work.
Oh.
But you know what?
I think I will put a little
probability of
raccoon table in here.
Because the next thing I
want to do is I want to
go the other way.
This is recoding tallies
from some process so I
can develop a model.
But once I've got these
probabilities, of course, then
I can start to simulate what
the model would do.
All right?
How would I do that?
Well, do I want to use
the same table?
I think just to keep things
sanitary, what I'll do is I'll
go over here and do it again.
Here's B. It's got a probability
of B. Here's R.
Here's a table probability of
R. That comes down into a
joint table for dog.
And it's got four elements.
Depending on the burglar
condition and the raccoon
condition, we get a probability
of dog.
And now, imagine these have
all been filled in.
So what do I want to do if I
want to simulate this system
generating some combination of
values for all the variables?
Well, I do the opposite of what
I did when I was working
around with this chain rule
showing that I could go from
the table to those
probabilities.
Now I've got the
I'm going to go the
other direction.
Instead of chewing away from the
bottom, I'm going to chew
away from the top.
Because when I go into the top
and chew way, everything I
need to know to do a
coin flip is there.
So in particular, when I go
up in here, I've got the
probability of burglar now.
So I'm going to use that
probability to flip a coin.
Say it produces a T. So that
takes care of this guy.
And I can now scratch it off
since it's no longer in
consideration.
It's no longer a top variable.
So now I go over into raccoon
and I do the same thing.
I take this probability.
I do a flip.
And say it produces an F.
Whatever its probability is, I
flip a biased coin and that's
what I happen to get.
But now, having dealt with these
two guys, that uncovers
this dog thing.
And I've got enough information,
because I've done
everything above, to make the
calculation for whether to dog
is going to be barking or not.
But wait.
I have to know that I've got a T
and a T and a T and an F and
an F and a T and an F and an
F. Because I have to select
the right row.
So I know that B is T. And I
know that R is F. So that
takes me into the table
into the second row.
So now I get this probability.
I flip that coin and I get some
result, say, T. Voila.
I can do that with the
other two variables.
And I've got myself an
experimental trial that is
produced in accordance with the
probabilities of the table.
OK?
Of course--
yeah, in fact, how did
I get those numbers?
Actually what I did is I used
the model on the left to
generate the samples that
were used to compute the
probabilities on the right.
So you've seen that a
demonstration of this already.
Now of course--
I don't know, all of this sort
of depends on having
everything right.
I've written a thing to write
it one more time.
Burglar, raccoon, dog, call
the police, trashcan.
But somebody else may say, oh,
you've got it all wrong.
This is what it really
looks like.
The dog doesn't care about
the raccoon at all.
So that's a correct model.
Now when I do a simulation, I
could fill in the tables in
either model, right?
I'm sure you'd like to
see a demonstration.
So let me show you a
demonstration of that.
So there are the two tables.
And I can run 10,000
simulations
on those guys, too.
Now, look.
The guy on the left is a pretty
good reflection of the
probabilities in a model I
used to produce the data.
But the guy on the right doesn't
know any better. it
just fills in its
own tables, too.
So what to do?
I say this one's the
right model.
And you say that one's
the right model.
Who's right?
Maybe we'll never know.
And the guy on the left will get
rich in the stock market
and the guy on the right
will go broke.
I would be nice if
we could actually
figure out who's right.
So would you to see how to
figure out who's right?
Yeah, so would I. What we're
going to do is we're going to
look at naive Bayesian
inference.
And that's our next chore.
So here's how it works.
We know, from the definition of
conditional probability, we
know that the probability of
A given B is equal to the
probability of A and
B divided by the
probability of B, right?
Equal to by definition.
So that means that the
probability of A given B times
the probability of B--
I'm just multiplying it out--
it equal to that joint
probability.
Oh, but by symmetry, there's no
harm in saying I can turn
that around and say that the
probability of B given A times
the probability of B is also
equal to that joint
probability, right?
I've just expanded it a
different and symmetric way.
If I've got to write a, b on
B, b, a on A. Thank you.
Who was complaining?
Good work.
That would have been a
major-league disaster.
But now, having written that, I
can forget about the middle.
Because all I'm really
interested in is how I've
turned the probabilities around
in that conditional.
Why would I care about
doing that?
By the way, we're now talking
about the work of
the Reverend Bayes.
Because we can rewrite this yet
again as the probability
of A given B is equal to the
probability of B given A times
the probability of A divided
by the probability of B.
That's just elementary
algebra.
But now I'm going to do
something magical.
I'm going to say I've got a
classification problem.
I want to know which
disease you have.
That's a classification
problem.
Maybe you've got
the swine flu.
Maybe you've got indigestion.
Who knows.
But I get all these symptoms.
I get all these pieces
of evidence.
You've got a fever.
You're throwing--
oh, well, let's not go into
too much detail, there.
But what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say, well, let's
suppose that A is equal to a
class that I'm interested in,
the disease you've got.
And B is equal to the evidence,
the symptoms I observe.
Voila.
I may have a pretty hard time
figuring out what the
probability of the class
is given the evidence.
But figuring out the probability
of the evidence
given the class might
not be so hard.
Let me get another board in play
and show you what I mean.
By plugging class and evidence
into Bayes' rule, what I get
is the probability of some class
given the evidence is
equal to the probability of the
evidence given the class
times the probability of the
class divided by the
probability of the evidence.
Now you've got to let that
sing to you a little bit.
Suppose I've got several classes
that I'm trying to
decide between.
I'm trying to select the best
out of that batch of classes.
Well, I've got the evidence.
And if I know the probability of
the evidence given each of
those classes, and if I know,
a priori, the initial
probability the class,
then I'm done.
Because I've got the two
elements in the numerator.
Why am I done?
Because the denominator is the
same for all the classes.
It's just the probability
of the evidence.
And then I could just
sum everything up.
I know it adds to 1 anyway.
So that's cool.
But sometimes there's
evidence--
actually there's more than
one piece of evidence.
Let's say that there's
some class.
some i, and we're trying to
figure out if that's the
correct class.
So we've got c sub i there
and c sub i there.
And suppose that that evidence
is actually a bunch of pieces
of evidence.
So it could be e sub
1, e sub n, oops,
premature right bracket.
All that evidence, given the
class i times the probability
of the class i over some
denominator that we don't care
about because it's going to
be the same for everybody.
So we'll just write that as d.
Now what if these pieces of
evidence are all independent
given the class?
So if you have the swine flu,
the probability you have a
fever is independent of the
probability you're going to
throw up, say.
Then can we write this
another way?
An easier way?
Sure.
Because when things are
independent, the joint
probability is equal to the
product of the individual
probabilities.
So that is to say--
it's easier to see it if you
write it down than if
you just say it--
this probability here from these
two elements here is
equal to the probability of e
sub 1 conditioned on c sub i
times the probability of e sub
2 conditioned on c sub i, all
the way down to the probability
of e sub n
conditioned on c sub i divided
by some denominator we don't
care about.
See, what I'm going to try to do
is I'm going to go through
this for all the ci and see
which one's the biggest.
STUDENT: That's the [INAUDIBLE]
ci, right?
PROFESSOR PATRICK WINSTON: This
is the probability of--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
right-hand side [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR PATRICK WINSTON:
Right here?
Oh yes, you're quite right.
Oh yeah, thanks.
I can't write and think
at the same time.
Thanks.
OK.
So I've just figure out which
one of these is the biggest.
And I've identified the class.
Now you say to me, well, I would
like to see an example.
So--
I don't know, does anyone
have any spare change?
A nickel, a quarter.
This is not because of
infinitesimally low raises
here at MIT.
I just need it for
a demonstration.
I need two coins.
Don't forget to get these
back, I tend to be--
Now suppose these two coins
are not exactly the same.
One of these points is a
legitimate, highly-prized
American quarter.
The other one is a fake.
And with this one, the
probability of heads, let us
say, is 0.8 instead of 0.5.
So I mix these all up.
And I pick one.
And I start flipping it.
And I get a head.
Then I flip it again.
And I get a tail.
Which coin did I pick?
Well, we're going to use this
stuff to figure it out.
Here's what happens.
Before I forget.
Thank you very much.
So what we've done is
we've selected these
things from my hands.
And I can't draw hands.
So I'll draw a little
cup here.
And there are two
coins in here.
And we're going to pick one.
And one has a probability
of heads equal to 0.8.
And this one has a probability
of a head of 0.5.
So here's the draw.
I pick one.
Each has a probability of 0.5.
This one is the one with
the 0.8 as the
probability of head.
And this one is the
one with the
probability of 0.5 as a head.
OK?
So now suppose the first flips
as it was is T. Well, that's a
piece of evidence.
That's here.
Probably of evidence
given the class.
Well in the case of having drawn
this biased coin, the
probability of coming up with a
tail-- ah, let's say a head,
just to make my numbers
a little easier.
Probability of coming out there
with a head is equal 0.8
given that it's up here
in this choice.
The probability given that you
have a fair coin is 0.5.
So now if we take the next coin
and take it to be a tail
then the probability
of this guy given
that evidence is 0.2.
And the probability of this guy
given that evidence-- it's
a fair coin, so it
doesn't care.
It's still 0.5.
So now what's the probability
of this
class given this evidence?
It's the product 0.5 times
0.8 times 0.2.
And what's the probability
of this guy?
It's 05 times 0.5 times 0.5,
divided by a denominator which
is the same in both cases.
So let's forget about
this early 0.5 here.
Because it's the same
in both cases.
And we just multiply those
numbers together.
That gives us 0.8 times 0.2.
What's that?
0.16?
And this guy, 0.5 times
0.5, that's 0.25.
So it looks an awful lot like--
with this combination--
that I've picked the
coin that's fair.
One more flip?
So let's flip it again,
and suppose we
come up with a head.
So that puts a 0.8 in here.
And 0.5 in here.
When you multiply those
out that's 0.125.
And this is 0.128.
So it's about equal.
So you see how that works?
All right.
So we're using the coin flips
as evidence to figure out
which class is involved.
OK so I don't know, you'd
probably like to see a
demonstration of this,
too, right?
You say to me, gosh, just
two kinds of coins.
That's not very interesting.
Let's try five kinds of coins.
So what I want to show you is
how the probabilities for all
these coins-- there are five
of them, color-coded--
how the probabilities vary
with a series of flips.
Let's suppose I've
got a head--
the grey line, by the way, is
the fraction of heads--
so that's going to be one.
Because I'm just doing heads.
You see that black
line rising?
Should look like a rocket.
That's the probability
that the--
that's the coin which only shows
heads, the probability
of head is 1.
And I'm flipping a whole
bunch of heads here.
Isn't that cool?
Now what happens if I suddenly
put in a tail?
By the way, you'll no doubt,
here one the extreme left--
the initial probability of
the P=0 coin was 0.1.
As soon as I flipped a
head that went to 0.
And it will never get
off 0, right?
That makes sense.
Because if the probability that
you'll get a head is 1
you should never see a tail.
If you ever do, that
isn't your coin.
What happens now if I interrupt
a series of heads
and produce a tail?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR PATRICK WINSTON:
What's that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR PATRICK WINSTON: The
black one will go to 0.
What else happens?
By the way, the blue one is
the one with the highest
probability of being a head.
[INAUDIBLE]
Boom!
That blue one shot up.
Not going up slowly.
It shot up.
Because now the preponderance
of evidence with all those
heads is that I've flipped the
coin with a bias of 0.75
towards heads.
So let's clear this.
Pick any probability you want.
0.25, 0.5, and so on.
I don't know, let's pick
0.25 since we've been
at the upper end.
So orange is 0.25.
And sure enough, the probability
that I've selected
the 0.5 coin is going up and
up and up and up after the
original irregularity.
The Law of Large Numbers
is setting in.
And a probability that I've got
that 0.25 coin in play is
pretty close to 1.
All right.
So that's cool.
Now you say to me, that's
awfully nice but stop.
Awfully nice, but not
very real-world-ish.
So let me give you
another problem.
It's well-known that you are,
with high probability, of the
same political persuasion
as your parents.
So if I wanted to figure out
which party a parent belongs
to, I could look at the
party that their
children belong to, right?
So it's just like
flipping coins.
The particular coin
I have chosen
corresponds to the parent.
Individual flips correspond to
the political party that the
child belongs to.
So let's get up a little bit--
by the way, I wrote all this
stuff over the weekend.
So who knows if any
of it will work.
But let's see.
A parent party classifier.
There it is, Democrats
and Republicans.
And now the prior for being a
Republican given here is 0.5.
But I don't know, this is a
little bit Democratic state.
So let's adjust that
down a little bit.
Somewhere in there might be
about right But let's just,
for the sake of a classroom
illustration, go down here.
So now the meter is showing the
prior probability because
that's the only thing in
the formula so far.
I've got no evidence.
So now let's suppose that
child number one is a
Republican.
Back to neutral.
So I've got a low probability
that the parent--
a priori probability that the
parent is a Republican and a
child who's a Republican.
I notice that 0.2 and 0.8,
the conditional is 0.8.
And the prior is 0.2.
That's why it comes out to
balance each other, right?
So now if we get another
Republican in
there it goes way up.
If I have a Democratic child
it goes back down.
If I have an equal balance
between children then it goes
way back down because of that
prior probability being low.
So if I make that high, even
though the children are
balanced, I'm still going to
have a high probability of
being a Republican.
Now let's see.
If I take that slider there, the
conditional probability,
and drive it to the left
here-- let me make that
equally in.
And let's make that one thing.
I don't know.
What am I doing now?
If I make the probability less
than 0.5, what's that mean?
That means you're sore at your
parents and you want to belong
to a different party.
All right, so now,
what's next?
Oh gosh.
What's next?
This is what's next.
What's next to somewhere?
Yeah, this is what's next.
This here.
We've got two models.
Remember when I said we wanted
to decide between them?
Can we use that Bayesian
hack to do that, too?
Sure.
Because we've got these
two models.
We've got the probabilities
in them.
So now I can take my data and
calculate the probability of a
left model given the data and
the probability of the right
model given the data, multiply
that times their a priori
probabilities, which I'll
assume are equal.
Then I can do a model selection
deal much in
defiance to what I was
hinting at before.
so let's try that.
Whoa.
There are my two models.
Yes, there they are.
We've already trained them up.
And they've got their
probabilities.
Now what we're going to do
is we're going to use the
original model to simulate
the data.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to simulate draws,
simulate events, similarly
combinations of all variables
using a model that looks like
the one on the left, that is
the one on the left except for
the slight differences in
probabilities, OK?
Then we're going to do this
Bayesian thing and see where
the meter goes.
So we'll run one data point.
Oops, went the wrong way.
Makes me nervous.
I just finished this at 9:15.
Maybe there's a bug.
Oops, two data points,
swings to the left.
Three data points, back
to the right.
Of course that's
not much data.
So let's put some
more data in.
Yeah.
Boom, there it goes.
Let's try that again.
That was cool.
So let's run 1,000 simulations
and one data point.
It bobbles around a little
bit and goes
flat over to the left.
Because that is the model that
reflects the one that the data
is generated from.
So now we got Bayesian
classification, except now the
classification has gone one
step more and it becomes
structure discovery.
We've got two choices
of structure.
And we can use this Bayesian
thing to decide which of the
two structures is best.
Isn't that cool?
Well, it's only cool if
you could do what?
So if you had two choices--
you can select between them
and pick the best one--
but there are--
gosh, for this number of
variables, there are a whole
lot of different networks that
satisfy the no looping
criteria and don't have
very many parents.
There's an awful lot of them.
In fact, if you strict this
network to two parents there
are probably thousands and
thousands of possible
structures.
So do I try them all?
Probably not.
It's too much work when you
get 30 variables or
something like that.
So what do you do?
We know what to do, right?
We're almost veterans a 6034.
We have to search!
So what we do is we take the
loser and we modified it.
And then we modify it again.
And we keep modifying it until
we drop dead or we get
something that we're
happy with.
So let's see what happens if
we change this problem a
little bit and do structure
discover.
We're starting out with
nothing linked.
And we're going to just start
running this guy.
So what's going to happen
is that the
good guy will prevail.
And the bad guy will be
a copy of the good guy
perturbed in some way.
So it's a random search.
You'll notice that score--
it's too small for
you to read.
All these things are
too small to read.
Let me make it a
little bigger.
Too small to read, but that
number on the right there is
not the product of the
probabilities, actually.
It's the sum of the logarithms
of the probabilities.
They go together, right?
And the reason you use this
instead of the probabilities
is because these numbers get
so small that was a 32-bit
machine, you eventually lose.
So use the log of the
probabilities rather than the
product of the probabilities.
You use the sum of the logs
instead of the product of the
probabilities.
And eventually, you hope that
this thing converges on the
correct interpretation.
But you know what?
This thing is so flat as a space
and so a large and so
telephone pole-like that it's
full of local maxima.
So what this program is doing
is every once in awhile--
I think with probability
1 and 10; I forgot what
parameters I used--
every once in awhile, it'll do
a total radical rearrangement
of the structures.
In other words, it's
a random restart.
It keeps track of the
best guy so far.
And every once in awhile it does
a totally random restart
in its effort to search
the space.
So that's how you go from
probabilistic inference to
structure discovery.
Now when is this stuff
actually useful?
Well, I hinted at a medical
diagnosis, right?
That's a situation where you've
got some symptoms.
And you want to know what
the disease is.
So as soon as you use the
keyword "diagnosis," you've
got a problem for which this
stuff is a candidate.
So what other kinds of diagnosis
problems are there?
Well, you might be
lying to me.
So I can put a lie
detector on you.
And each of those variables that
are measured by the lie
detector are an independent
indication whether you're
telling the truth or not.
So it's this kind of Bayesian
discovery thing.
Naive Bayesian Classification.
What other kinds of
problems speak to
the issue of diagnosis?
Well, we like to know how well
you know the material!
So we can use quizzes as
pieces of evidence.
Thank god we don't use exactly
a naive Bayesian classifier,
because then we wouldn't be able
to do that combination.
We have to use a slightly
more complex--
what you can think of as a
slightly more complex Bayesian
net to do that particular
kind of diagnosis.
You might have a spacecraft or
an airplane or other piece of
equipment with all sorts
of symptoms.
You're trying to figure
out what to do next,
what the cause is.
So using the evidence to go
backward to the cause.
So maybe you've got some program
that doesn't work.
Happens to me a lot.
So I use the evidence from the
symptoms of the misbehavior to
figure out what the most
probable cause is.
But now to conclude the day--
last time there weren't any
powerful ideas.
But if you take the combination
of the last
lecture and this lecture to be
a candidate for gold star
ideas, these are the ones I'd
like to leave you with.
We got here is--
this Bayesian stuff, all these
probabilistic calculations are
the right thing to do.
They're the right way to work
when you don't know anything,
which would make it sound like
you're not very useful,
because you think you always--
well, in fact, there are a lot
of situations where you either
can't know everything, don't
have time to know everything,
or don't want to take the
effort to know everything.
So in medical diagnosis all
you've got is the symptoms.
You can't go in there and figure
out in a more precise
way exactly what's wrong.
So you use the symptoms to
determine what the cause is.
And then all those other kinds
of cases that I mentioned.
But now, what other kinds of
structure discovery are there?
Well, the kind of structure
discovery that I hinted at in
the beginning will be the
subject that we'll begin with
during our next and sadly final
conversation here in
[? 10250 ?]
on Wednesday.
It will feature not only a
discussion of how this stuff
can be used to discover patterns
and stories, but
we'll also talk about what's
on the final, what kind of
thing you could do next, that
sort of thing to finish off
the subject.
And that's the end of
the story for today.